head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
I wanna I wanna pop this sweet guys we
need this everyone everyone we're going
to go through these exercises
the New York Times says elections and
anxiety often go hand in hand here are
some evidence-based strategies that can
help you cope
with what
try five finger breathing trace the
outside of your hand with your pointer
finger when you trace up breathe in and
when you trace down breathe out
oh
breathing like that just makes you angry
like nervous like somebody's like here's
your breath I'm like here's what we're
gonna see it's gonna be that woman
screaming no again but she's gonna drop
20s ago no
they're gonna change the the Tommy fists
to the the five finger pointing here we
go cool down listen oh no guys guys guys
plunge your face into a bowl with ice
water for 15 to 30 seconds yo what is
going on that sounds fun dude I'm troll
this is New York Times New York Times
that's very look at this move wait it
gets better guys move even a walk around
the block can offer some relief a relief
or an Aussie uneasy mind here you go
breathe like a baby focus on expanding
your belly as you breathe which can send
more oxygen to the brain limit your
scrolling consider plotting out specific
times when you will look for election
updates I gotta say it I gotta say it
Elon Musk starts Banning a bunch of
these whiny lunatics user growth is at
all-time highs and they're they're
having temper tantrums I am so happy to
see Elon grounding the naughty children
because they're children that's what
they are when when I when I'm watching
election results
I'm not crying I'm sitting here and I'm
like well this will be interesting we'll
see what happens when when Joe Biden won
I had a video I'm like there it is
they've announced the winner it's Joe
Biden and the left made a Supercut of
that as if I was crying about it and I'm
like I just literally said he won I'm
not mad like right what are you talking
like you guys are you these people have
to put their face in a bowl of ice water
right now because of the results aren't
even in and the New York Times is
telling everyone please keep calm calm
down yo in Portland let's jump to this
one in Portland they're getting ready
where's this where's the silly tweet
they're boarding up Windows look at this
look at this look at this video
here we go back to the office
I noticed several businesses
we're boarding up their Windows now why
would they be doing that
they're expecting a red wave that's why
because the only people that complain
are look at the banks Wells Fargo
they're boarding up their windows
our Rite Aid down there
not a bad idea closed closed Payless
closed
wow
that's their new normal dude down here I
gotta retweet this one pretty soon I bet
you Chase Bank over there is gonna board
up their Windows because you know how
some of these people in Portland get
that's right that's right the New York
Times wants to make sure that you try
five finger breathing dude when these
this is the problem with the internet
you have the with Twitter particularly
you have these journalists who are just
like I'm being harassed and it's like
someone who says you're dumb and they're
just like they they someone calls them
dumb so they quote tweet it and they go
like we're in hell and I'm like dude
someone insulted you have you never been
in a city before I find that crazy too
like or all the people who are like oh I
get horrible things in my DMs it's like
okay I know everybody else who doesn't
you can turn off your DMs welcome to the
internet solves the problem in a crazy
so funny you know people say they get
death threats like that doesn't mean
they're credible or that anyone is right
or like the ones that are like you know
when people tell you to kill yourself
it's like oh okay
that's really convincing and the problem
is I'm gonna run and do that they keep
pandering to this so in the past the
advertisers would be like hey people are
crying to us and they're complaining and
they'd be like don't worry we'll take
care of it now elon's like don't care
band shut up because they're the ones
who believe that Twitter is a privilege
and not a right like they're they think
that free expression is a privilege and
if you break their rules you should get
kicked off no now it's now it's not
being enforced without a double standard
but now it's a right now the same people
that were like a private company are
like Elon Musk is a tyrant yeah so
here's so here's what happens you you
saw everybody changing their names Elon
Musk you guys saw that all these actors
they did that because someone made the
point that once anyone can be verified
impersonation will be a problem I'll
prove it by changing my name to Elon
Musk they instantly get banned and then
they're like but I was doing parody like
wait hold on your point was
impersonation is dangerous and that we
can't tolerate it Twitter has never
tolerated impersonations they banned you
now you're complaining you should be
allowed to do it these people are not
serious they are not serious people
they're not arguing any real positions
so I don't care to listen to what they
have to say now they're like this is
such a loss for free speech like they
were the champions of
count no yeah that's why I did that she
hopped onto her Dead Mother's account to
impersonate Elon Musk on that account
again and get into it back and forth
with him on Twitter again she was like
my mom won't mind me doing this right
what's your mom would like it I forget
what it was it was like
her mother's name was like Maggie
Griffin Maggie Griffin I don't know if
that one has also been suspended since
then yeah maybe Maggie Griffin Kathy is
is trending
yeah how ghoulish you know hair what is
this and she's like my mother would have
been okay with this you don't understand
like the severed head wasn't ghoulish
enough yeah she always takes things too
far huh she's just gross she's ugly to
look at too
from the New York Post is that it
Catherine giving you his late Mom's
account to evade Twitter ban like what a
ghoul yeah
yeah I like a steaming cup of my own
urine in the morning
so what pissed me about the story is
that Elon was giving him special
treatment again
the rules are you can impersonate if
you're verified period And so Elon said
no no fine fine I'll let you do it as
long as you put parity in your name and
they went no and it's like okay with
your band like don't give them a
specialty they changed their name to
Elon Musk ban it's always been the rule
sorry goodbye I think there should be
some kind of path to Redemption but as I
stated yesterday I am not going to
advocate for any of these people to get
their accounts back because they oppose
Free Speech well that's not free speech
that's like identity theft right but
someone's identifying the real if you
steal someone's identity in the real
world
it has nothing to do with free speech if
someone's house is on fire that's what
they've been claiming but if someone's
house they've been crying saying I have
free speech saying elon's not for free
speech if someone's house is on fire and
I don't like them I will I will call
9-1-1 and be like let's help them put
this fire even though I don't like them
if someone is an arsonist and they're
setting fires and then they get burned
by it I'm not gonna call 9-1-1 because
they deserve help I'm gonna call it
because the fire is a problem and needs
to be stopped my point is I don't want
anybody get hurt by fire I don't want
anyone get get banned when they're
engaging in free speech but I'm not
going to to help an arsonist this is not
going to happen I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna advocate for these people and you
know it's just not going to happen well
these these Skittle people are just a
bunch of [ __ ] dude I mean at the end
of the day yeah they just the rainbow
Mafia you know these are the same people
that are running around threatening
everyone threatening to bash your face
in but they can't handle a word this is
why they want to change words because if
you say words that are too offensive
they can't handle it in reality that's
the thing is who these people are
they're pathetic they're pathetic and
they don't represent America because if
you did you would be able to stand on
your own two feet and be offended in the
face of anything that opposes you but
they can't the children their children
this is what Kathy hokel has been doing
in New York right this is why I think
that yeah this is what she's been doing
she has changed uh she spent all of this
energy and money to change
um the word inmate to incarcerated
person in all legislation as if this
means anything at all apparently the
word inmate was offensive but like if
you change a word that you think is
offensive to a different word shortly
thereafter that word becomes offensive
as well no prisoner was offended no
inmate is offensive
they've changed all the gender language
in in the in the state legislation about
this incarcerated person we are thankful
when I when my son was in like a
kindergarten they had this rule that you
couldn't say stupid because it would
make people feel bad so the kids
bullying so the kids started calling
each other out yeah it totally is so the
kids started calling each other silly
and then silly became a bad word kids
are mean and I'd be like this is stupid
like it's just how just socialization
words yes anti-bullying was always yeah
anti-bullying is a mistake and like as
someone who was mercilessly bullied like
you grow up and it's fine and you're
resilient like suck it
you know life is hard they're like get
used to it early yeah you're gonna get
pissed off people are not gonna like you
that's what's crazy is these people want
to be put on the Forefront like beyond
the news they want to be like blowing up
on Tick Tock and social media but then
they get criticized and they run away
and claim it's hate speech and put their
talent between their legs because like I
said well you know what then they do
then they breathe like babies right what
was the five finger breathing thing they
were saying and tomorrow all of these
people will have to cope and they will
too
that's why there's that like that
demonics
family friendly drew the screaming is
like the craziest part like the thing at
Penn State yeah like are you possessed
like is there something literally wrong
with you like they know who's remarkably
resilient to this stuff is Dylan
Mulvaney
well because why are you so good at
handling the online bullying well then
he is a performer Mulvaney is a bully
intending to insult trans people you
will never convince me otherwise I don't
know about it you think it's a I I think
I think people on the right are so eager
to look at trans people as Dylan
Mulvaney that they accept what is
clearly a troll designed to insult when
a dude put on when they used to put on
blackface they didn't act like black
people they acted like insane
caricatures to mock them the way they
painted their faces Dylan Mulvaney and
what was for the longest time making
social media content was I believe a gay
man yes and now all of a sudden all of
these videos are just the most insane
mockeries of women and trans people it's
been a great career and mulvania is
getting praise and protection from it
while mocking women and trans people
it's worse than that it's worse than
that he's not he's not impersonating a
woman
it's a little he's impersonating a
little girl right
he's not impersonating a female adult
even more mentally ill and deranged
this is the issue you fell for it
to me that you guys believe this it's a
little girl drinking hormones please has
one breast bigger than another but it's
just committed this is
all right what did I fall for a guy who
wore hiking heels uh-huh and you're like
that's a legitimate human that's a
that's a real that's a real thing no
he's a weirdo that thinks that that's
how women actually he said he's
performing he said he's doing a bit he
said it he said he's not in the White
House yeah
he's doing a bit and Performing and he
wants to be a performer and this is his
performance he doesn't want to be a
performer he is a performer this is a
career move prior to doing this he was
doing tick tocks where he was
interviewing animals as a gay man he
went on The Price is Right and won a
massive pool table and had a great time
it was actually kind of a good segment
on that show but this this move to be
trans to be like a little trans girl or
whatever brilliant career
movement
opportunistic gay man it's a performance
he's an actor he's an actor you look at
I will I will cite as I did before Blair
white and uh uh Contra points these are
two trans people one person's uh left
left sphere of influence right sphere of
influence they don't wear hiking heels
they don't flail about and fall down
when dragonflies come by they don't talk
about Barbie pouches they don't say it's
time to normalize the Bulge that is not
what a real trans person is going around
doing the argument so so what happens is
so what you're doing too is you're doing
what like the anti-trans activists the
like gender critical people would call
giving into the idea of true trans what
I'm saying is we had Blair white on here
talking about you know actually when
we've had Blair on several times we've
not really talked about transitions
because I don't know just we talk about
politics well Blair's very smart person
and Blair was talking about like she
said that Dylan is legit legit like
people actually think you know I I I I
think it's it's you're being trolled but
I think conservatives want this to be
the caricature of trans people yeah they
want it to be that way well it's like
that like you look at Blair and you're
like why is it Blair acting like that
because that's not because I think that
I think there's still like a a spectrum
of mentally ill trans people more normal
trans people like this especially right
but what you're saying is Arrested
Development but but he is still going
through like that but what you're saying
isn't all the things some people are
mentally ill some people are not
mentally ill so therefore you might have
someone like Blair who's a very smart
individual uh and very you know you know
reasonable and then Dylan Mulvaney is
trans and also happens to have other
mental illnesses including arrested yeah
Arrested Development I stuck in that
like so do you think Dylan is grifting
even the left
and you think that he got into the White
House because he's playing and drifting
his base come on dude normal I'm just
asking you man yes yes can we say this
and still doing it at the same time like
it he's a gay man that probably saw an
opportunity by being trans he's
exploiting it but he's still going
through all the things because that's
what's going to make him money so it's
like a double right he's screwing women
screwing the trans people screwing the
trans let's just say trans kids right so
he's screwing all of them at the same
time because he's pulling a grift on all
of them so he doesn't really care about
trans people he just wants to be famous
did we take Rachel dolas all seriously
like the way I see Dylan Mulvaney would
be if someone put on blackface and
started running around demanding
watermelon and fried chicken it's like
that is insanely wrong offensive and
stereotypical that's not reality
Dylan Mulvaney is doing all the things
all those things 10 times hiking heels
but look at these crazy normalize the
Bulge those are performances don't we
think that there is an amount of
performance and fakery and non-reality
to all transgenderism not all
expressions of it
I mean all of it is artificial no the
hormone therapy the surgeries
stuff it's all artificial and cosmetic
it there's a performance people are
trying to present a certain way
so like this is what this is what Blair
white was talking about and it's
probably it's it's Blair's a better
person to talk about it than I would be
she mentioned the difference between
gender dysphoric individuals and
fetishist individuals correct and
they're not the same can't they overlap
though
well anybody can overlap that's that's
not an argument you can you can be uh
I'm just saying you can be a communist
and trans person you can be a trump
supporting trans person right there's
overlap and all sorts of ideologies the
point I'm making without getting into
the greater all of the trans stuff is
that Dylan Mulvaney I just look at that
and I'm like the first thing anyone
should think when they see Dylan
Mulvaney saying normalize the Bulge is
like this is a gag this is not real this
is not this isn't this first of all
we've not seen something like this it's
over the top tenfold and going into the
woods wearing like women's biking
outfits and high heels is not a real
thing I don't think any of trans is a
real thing but there is but transvestite
White's a real person who exists okay
I'm not that's like you're denying our
existence I'm not denying that people
who identify as trans are real I'm
saying that the identity is artificial
what I'm saying is there's not a woman
that frolics around in the forest in
Heights yeah he does it like way over
the top and he's kind of big guys it's a
gag but there is transvestite fetishism
right or whatever you say
yeah right and what that is is that they
get off like having other people totally
African woman dresses a little girl
dresses all those things and I think yes
and I think it's a totally conversation
that he's grifting off of it getting off
on off of it like if you watch it
because I've gone down like that Tick
Tock like feed look endlessly that's
that's that's that's there's nothing
indicating that he's having like that
this is getting him off like oh he talks
about he talks about like saying oh my
gosh I'm I'm dreaming about the way the
this guy gonna kiss me and he's seeing
me as a girl and like he talks about the
stuff like you can clearly tell he's
getting off on it in in some way I don't
We're not gonna solve this now and we
should probably get back to election
stuff yeah my point was just sorry for
bringing him up my point was just simply
that when a person does as many
cartoonish things that insult trans
people and then everyone on the right is
like Taha see that's what trans people
are I'm like dude come on
like I think it's an extreme expression
of what all of that is I don't like I I
guess but he says he's performing
and he he was doing tons of videos as a
man and then all of a sudden starts
doing these gag videos like I will I
would say wearing high heels in the
woods is a gag it was a it was a joke
saying normalize the Bulge and then
trying later to walk it back after trans
people started calling him out then he
was like oh no I was just he put about
put out a video saying like I was just
self-conscious and didn't really mean it
and it's like but I don't think I don't
I don't think he's that uh out of the
normal though I don't think he's over
the top it completely is over the top
now another person saying normalized but
like when you go to these protests Tim
we were we were in Nashville at Matt
Walsh's thing and it's all those kinds
of people running around screaming
foaming at the mouth like their eyes
rolling back so okay so all dressed the
same way yes yes totally mentally ill
you cannot address this full every
single person that's not what I'm saying
that's what I'm saying is that there
still is people in the left that are
over the top like okay on the ground
when you go see them I know I know for
sure
issue is the the handful of grifting uh
fake ideological individuals are not
representative of the General Public
like simply put when you go to an antifa
crowd you are looking at a group of
antifa mentally ill people that's what
they are all of them
that you you don't go around smashing
windows and burning buildings down
unless you have some serious mental
problem so like I'm not going to look at
antibond be like look at all these white
people yeah antifa tends to be
overwhelmingly white I'm not going to go
there and be like well white people are
clearly mentally ill because antifa is
it's like no those are the unwell people
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time